Riddle us this: who's an actor that's already
played one comic book bad guy and could be
making the leap from Marvel Studios to the
DC Extended Universe to play a Batman villain?
According to We Got This Covered, Chiwetel
Ejiofor, who played the villainous Mordo in
Doctor Strange, is in consideration to play
the Riddler in director Matt Reeves' The Batman.
The upcoming flick will purportedly feature
a bevy of baddies for Batman to face.
It's expected that the Riddler, whose given
name is Edward Nygma, a play on the word "enigma,"
will be included in the film's slew of villains.
"Oh...Bruce Wayne!"
"No, that's my name.
And you are?"
"Nygma.
Edward.
Edward Nygma."
We Got This Covered claims that The Batman
will include "at least six or seven" supercrooks
for the Dark Knight to vanquish, with the
Riddler being "all but confirmed" for one
of the more prominent positions in the rogues
gallery.
The Riddler is the brainchild of writer Bill
Finger and artist Dick Sprang, first appearing
in Detective Comics #140 in 1948.
A criminal mastermind who relishes in complex
riddles and has a flair for the dramatic,
leaving clues at crime scenes for Gotham City
authorities to find and often boasting about
his genius-level intellect, the Riddler is
intensely competitive and obsessed with puzzles.
When the Riddler learned that he could get
away with cheating at games, he started a
life of crime, donning a green, black and
purple costume littered with question marks,
cheating people out of money and pride, and
styling himself as an enemy of Batman, whom
he deemed to be a worthy opponent in mental
combat.
The mere thought of Ejiofor, who was nominated
for an Oscar for his performance in 12 Years
a Slave, taking on the role of the Riddler
is worth getting excited about.
But by We Got This Covered's own admission,
it might not actually happen, for a couple
reasons.
Reportedly, Ejiofor is just one of a number
of actors Warner Bros. is said to be eyeing
to play the Riddler in The Batman, though
it's unclear as of this writing who else the
studio is sizing up for the role.
Additionally, if Ejiofor doesn't end up landing
the role of the Riddler, word is that he'll
secure a different gig.
We Got This Covered's report claims that Warner
Bros. has Ejiofor in mind for several different
roles, including famous Batman adversary Two-Face
and longtime Wayne family ally Lucius Fox.
"Didn't you get the memo?"
It seems plausible that Ejiofor will be involved
in The Batman in some capacity, likely as
a villain.
Not only did he impress as Mordo in the MCU,
but he also lent his gruff voice to the treacherous
lion Scar in the recent remake of The Lion
King.
Based on where the information is coming from,
it may be solid intel.
We Got This Covered notes that the source
who provided the intel that Ejiofor is on
a "wishlist" at Warner Bros. for The Batman
is the same source that dished up the info
that Robert Pattinson would be playing Batman
in the new film, breaking the news before
Variety confirmed it.
If Ejiofor does end up signing on to portray
the Riddler in The Batman, he'll follow in
the footsteps of Frank Gorshin, who played
the character on the 1960s live-action Batman
series and the 1966 film Batman; John Astin,
who took on the role for one two-part episode
in the second season of Batman; Cory Michael
Smith, who portrays the Riddler on Gotham;
and Jim Carrey, who played the villain in
1995's Batman Forever.
Director Reeves has stated that the film would
get in front of cameras around the end of
2019, so it's too early to say what Ejiofor's
role in the movie will be, if any.
Until Warner Bros., Reeves, or Ejiofor himself
comes forward to confirm his involvement,
we'll all have to cross our fingers and hope
for the best.
With any luck, the decision to bring Ejiofor
aboard The Batman will be much, much simpler
than any of the Riddler's wild puzzles.
"Ho-ho!
What is it that no man wants to have, yet
no man wants to lose?"
"A lawsuit!"
The Batman is set for release June 25, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about superhero
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.